[Musique]
cette petite fille qui a grandi trop
vite s'appelle prisilia son calvaire
commence à l'âge de 4 ans au lieu de
refaire le monde dans sa chambre
d'enfant avec ses héros de bande dessiné
la petite fille se voit remplacer sa
mère dans le lit
conjugal
elle la gardera durant 11
[Musique]
ans pendant toutes ces années elle sera
victime d'inceste par son père qui ne
sera jamais inquiété par la justice et
il y aura aussi son demi-frère qui
abusera d'elle lui sera condamné à 3 ans
de prison avec surc aujourd'hui c'est
une jeune femme de 20 ans déterminée et
bien dans sa tête que nous allons vous
faire découvrir l'inceste c'est son
combat voici son
histoire
[Musique]
j'avais 4 ans quand le fils de mon
géniteur a commencé à avoir des
attouchements
sexuels j'avais 4 ans quand la famille a
continué de s'agrandir et que j'ai dû
prendre très progressivement le rôle de
ma
génitrice mes géniturs dès qu'on a nos
règles on était des femmes on devait
avoir des relations sexuelles et ben
pour eux enfin c'était juste c'était
tout bon j'allais pouvoir tomber
enceinte peu de temps après ne plus
aller en cours et c'était
ça j'ai jamais eu de
responsabilité de rôle à jouer qui sont
en accord avec mon âge donc au final
avoir 5 ans je sais pas ce que c'est
avoir 10 ans 12 ans 13 ans 14 ou 15 ans
non plus j'ai finalement pas vraiment
une vite à dos parce que quand j'étais
placée ben il fallait apprendre
apprendre tout ce que les autres avaient
depuis leur naissance et que j'avais pas
pu acquérir parce que ben on m'avait pas
donné les
[Musique]
clés je sortais de de l'inexistence de
la
survie de tout ce qui s'était passé
toute cette horreur et j'arrive ouais
dans la vie enfin comme quelqu'un qui
arrive qui vient de naître et et qui
découvre qu'en fait on peut sourire on
peut parler on peut rire que il y a pas
forcément que des choses moches tout le
temps bonjour mesdames estce qu'on peut
vous laisser un petit
fly moi je suis partie dans une lutte
j'ai créé une page Facebook donc vous
avez le lien en bas où je vais raconter
mon histoire à quelques heures du procès
le procès qu'elle attend depuis des
années et qui va peut-être condamner ses
parents pour leurs actes prcilia
s'active son objectif sensibiliser les
gens sur l'inceste un sujet qui reste
encore très tabou en 2016 son espoir
qu'un maximum de personnes viennent au
tribunal inconsciemment c'est sans doute
une manière de ne plus être seul dans
cette
bataille depuis que je sais qu'il a le
tribunal il y a pas une journée où je
fais rien sinon ça va pas donc faut
constamment que je reste actif j'attends
que l'audience soit actif elle aussi
j'ai Besin qu'il ait des échanges qu'il
a des mots de posé c'est des choses que
j'attends depuis très longtemps et qui
ont été reporté depuis 6 mois donc c'est
6 mois d'attente assez longue qui
devrait se terminer et en tout cas
j'espère 6 heur d'attente pour prisilia
et son comité de soutien en partie
constitué de personnes qu'elle a
sensibilisé avant le procès l'anxiété
est palpable dans l'allée des pas perdus
pour la première fois les géniteurs de
prisilia comme elle les appelle sont
poursuivis selon les termes juridiques
pour soustraction à leur légale au point
de compromettre la santé la sécurité la
moralité et l'éducation en incitant leur
filles à entretenir des relations
sexuelles avec un homme
majeur l'inceste ne sera pas retenu car
au moment des faits il n'est pas inscrit
au code pénal une réalité difficile à
accepter pour la victime mais une petite
victoire lorsque le verdict tombe 6 mois
de prison avec surc sontonn coup c'est
la première fois depuis 20 ans tu as vu
la tête qu'ils ont
fait quand just leur a dit qu'il va leur
tomber dessus il y avait du monde pour
me donner la main au moment de la
sentence et et c'est juste les mots
coupables en fait enfin ça a fait des
Lumières à un moment les mot ouais le
mot coupable a été important parce que
ça veut dire qu'il y a pas rien nu comme
ils ont pu fa le faire croire durant
l'audience attention sur voie neuf le
train va partir voz monter en voiture et
ne pas gêner la fermeture des portes sur
neu attention au
[Musique]
départ une nouvelle page se tourne
Priscilia peut enfin continuer sa lutte
direction Paris à présent Isabelle
Steyer avocate spécialisée sur la
question de l'inceste en France va
consacrer du temps à la jeune femme le
but obtenir des clés juridiques pour
qu'elle continue à se reconstruire moi
j'avais porté plinte contre mon géniteur
il y a quelques années oui et la plainte
a été classée sans suite oui donc je
n'aurais jamais de condamnation sur cet
inceste que quand j'étais plus jeune et
je voulais savoir aujourd'hui pour les
victimes d'inceste qu'est-ce qui existe
au niveau de la loi au niveau des
procédures pour les victimes d'accord
alors déjà mon souci il est là c'est que
il n'y a pas de poursuite pour des faits
d'inceste l'inceste n'existe pas dans le
code pénal l'inceste n'existe pas dans
le Code
civil l'inceste n'existe pas dans le
code de l'action
sociale donc c'est un mot qui n'est qui
qui qui qui qui ne signifie rien pour un
juriste j'ai j'ai beaucoup milité j'ai
beaucoup entendu des des des jeunes
femmes et des jeunes garçons et des des
femmes de tout âge d'ailleurs hein parce
que souvent dans les longtemps après
elle m'en parle dans les divorces dans
les séparations ça ressort à un moment
donné hein donc on n'oublie jamais
euh se poser deux questions la question
de la presse ins
iption puisque dans la mesure où on
noublie jamais pourquoi est-ce que le
législateur devrait oublier ces
faitsl puisque ça vous suit toute une
vie et la deuxième question c'était la
définition d'inceste qu'est-ce que
l'inceste et sur ces deux
pointsl il y a de grandes discussions en
France et on narrive pas à se mettre
d'accord
[Musique]
un consensus a finalement été trouvé
entre les sénateur et les députés le 18
novembre dernier la prescription est
toujours de 20 ans à partir de la
majorité de la victime le grand
changement c'est que l'inceste a été
officiellement réintroduit dans le code
pénal à l'initiative du député Bernard
[Musique]
Roman
bonjour
bonjour de retour à la maison des
adolescen une structure que prisilia
connaît bien car il y a 2 ans elle y est
passée avec une amie pour avoir une
aide un petit peu changé ça énormément
changé il y avait pas tous les tableaux
cétait pas encore aménagé comme çaon
continue à faire une exposition par mois
tu veux que je te montre un petit peu ou
je
il existe plus de 80 maisons des
adolescents en France une par
département y compris dans les DomTom en
région Centre il y en
a demain un adolescent victime d'inceste
ou qui a des gros gros problèmes par
exemple au niveau alimentaire est-ce qu'
peut venir
naturellement vous demander de l'aide
parce que il sait pas où elle est à
l'extérieur alors c'est une très bonne
question et c'est une question difficile
c'est les maisons desant le principe
c'est la gratuité et la confidentialité
donc un jeune qui vient exprimer quelque
chose ici s'il veut que ça reste ici on
va préserver cette confidentialité sauf
quand on est face à des situations d'une
grande violence et en particulier sur
l'inceste là nous avons des obligations
de signalement à l'adolescence la la
notion de secret elle est paradoxale
c'est qu'à la fois je veux de l'aide
mais je veux pas forcément que l'on vois
ce que je veux dire euh donc dans la
majorité des situations on conserve
l'anonymat et la confidentialité et très
rarement sur 600 situations c'est quatre
ou CIN fois dans l'année tu vois où là
on va effectivement ne ne pas respecter
cette cette confidentialité on n a pas
le droit mais au-delà de la question du
droit ce ne serait pas bon pour le jeune
si une amie à toi te dit qu'elle a envie
de se suicider mais surtout garde-le
pour toi n'en parle à personne tu vas en
parler oui c'est impossible je plus des
médecins sont également présents pour
suivre les adolescents en malêtreè dès
qu'on a été anorexique ou
boulimique si ça s'inscrivait dans le
temps s'il y avait toujours des
séquelles parce que je sais que moi je
peux toujours avoir aujourd'hui ben des
problèmes avec la nourriture faut pas
perdre de vue que quand on a souffert de
quelque chose on prend ce qu'on peut
pour essayer de de pas trop souffrir et
dans un premier temps de fait ça soulage
problème c'est qu'ensuite la solution
devient en elle-même un problème et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut intervenir
ensuite ça dépend de la durée
c'est-à-dire que quand le corps a été
habitué à un certain type de
fonctionnement un certain type de
rapport à l'alimentation si ça duré
quelques mois je dirais on va s'en
défaire assez facilement si ça a duré
des années ben le corps en lui-même il a
pris ses habitudes et même
si la la raison première ça y est ça a
été réglé ça entre guillemets parce
qu'il reste la souffrance la cicatrice
mais disons si ça été travaillé bah le
corps lui aussi il fonctionne par
lui-même hein donc bon alors il faut un
certain temps je pense qu'il faut
accepter qu'il puisse y avoir une
vigilance à garder par rapport à
alimentation une petite fragilité et
puis je pense qu'avec le temps elle peut
s'éteindre tout doucement la
reconstruction de prisilia ne s'arrête
pas là elle passe aussi par le cadre
d'une structure familiale qu'elle a pu
avoir grâce à sa maman de cœur
rencontrée lors de sa seconde naissance
lorsqu'elle a osé parler de son inceste
mamso comme elle la nomme a su lui
transmettre l'amour dont elle a manqué
durant 20
ans dès que j'ai rencontré MSO il y a eu
un truc après en fait je saais pas dire
quoi parce que on a commencé à échanger
et en fait je sais pas ça enfin ça s'est
fait un peu enfin pour moi ça s'est fait
tout seul c'est marrant j'ai pas le même
sentiment moi je j'ai eu l'impression
que c'était une lente approche moi je
t'ai vu arriver h vers mOiin je t'ai
connu tu étais en CO2 on avait une
passion commune c'était le champ super
bo d'ailleurs tu as intérêt à continuer
et euh alors c'était des petites
attentions c'était tu te rappelles tu
sais tu m'avais offert il est là
d'ailleurs le le le coquillage hein le
coquillage une petite carte un petit mot
tiens j'écris ce poème tu veux bien le
lire bon voilà et puis euh je crois que
c'est tu as
attendu que je sois plus du
tout enfin qu'on ne soit plus du tout
dans un rapport de d'enseignant de prof
à à à à él
pour te
libérer je me souviens alors
complètement mais je je j'ai visualisé
la scène elle est assez
importante ce C j'avais quand même
quelques doutes et puis
ensuite bah tu savais pas trop hein les
rapports finalement tu avais un peu peur
qu'il change alors tu venais me voir je
me souviens d' un jour tu étais là et
puis tu me dis mais pourquoi tu fais
tout ça pour moi mais alors pour avoir
la cette phrase là il fallait que
j'attende 12 SMS toi planqué dans les
toilettes
moi dans la cuisine je peux te poser une
question oui mais c'est difficile à dire
mais vas-y préilia oui mais j'ai peur
que tu me répondes à côté je m souviens
trop bien en gros est-ce que je t'aime
quoi hein c'est ça tu voulais savoir si
je
t'aimais tu as eu la
réponse alors moi tu m'as fait un beau
cadeau pas plusieurs mais un très
gros c'est que un jour tu as décidé
d'arrêter de m'appeler
Sophie et euh
et le fait de m'appeler mamso mamso
c'est-à-dire ma maman Sophie ma maman
Sophie mais pas tout à fait ma maman
puisque on s'est pas rencontré tout de
suite on t'est rencontré à ta deuxiè
naissance et bien c'était une preuve de
confiance et ça m'a vraiment
touché mes projets d'avenir c'est de
vivre totalement de continuer à aller à
la fag de continuer à travailler en
parallèle parce que ça me donne une
énergie monstrueuse et il y a
aussi
de d'écrire un bouquin par exemple ça
j'y tiens et depuis assez longtemps
maintenant que j'ai fermé une boucle je
vais pouvoir aussi je pense raconter mon
histoire et voilà et ma vie mes
amis vivent comme une une femme et une
[Musique]
étudiante
quand on n pas le Foix et qu'on peut pas
lâcher parce que si on lâche il a tout
qui s'écroule et ben on reste battante
on reste courageuse j'ai besoin d'avoir
le
sourire les jours où j'ai pas le sourire
ça va
pas j'ai besoin de rigoler de d'échanger
avec les gens tout le temps c'est
ouais il faut
que je je glisse encore sur la société
et sur ce monde là que j'privoise
encore
[Musique]
apprivoiser ce monde avancer sans jamais
reculer accepter sa différence et en
faire une force c'est faire preuve de
résilience c'est tout ce qui représente
[Musique]
Priscilia